an official source has just confirmed to
me
that the will now in an effort to try to
end this blockade there will be a mobile
testing center
moved here to dover port to the front of
the queue which will
then allow drivers here to be tested and
to begin moving through this port
it's really about the only resolution
that there is to this because
as you can see all around here colin
there are
hundreds and hundreds of vehicles cars
fans
uh bigger vans lorries uh they're all
blocking this round about where we are
at the entrance
to the port and all the way down
into the town of dover itself all of the
side streets
uh you've got lorries on um people are
very angry indeed you were talking there
about uh
some of the scuffles earlier they were
contained by
the police fairly quickly but we've had
sporadic scuffles
since very angry people that just
want to get through after so many days
of being
stranded here and quite frankly they
don't believe
the official version of events that they
will get tested
in a speedy uh fashion at manston
airport and certainly they don't want to
join the end of a very very long queue
that even government officials
acknowledge
could be several days before they clear
that they want to get
through this port as quickly as possible
this is what you hear as well every
every
so often the horns going
by drivers here in a show of solidarity
frustration anger all of the above
they just want to get moving and of
course you've got an added problem
colin which is that although people
we believe are now starting to be tested
at manston airport
where do they come to if they've got a
ferry they can't get
to the very port and they're not going
to get anywhere near the ferry port
until all of these drivers have been
tested
and allowed to go on their journey
across
to france so it's a really
difficult situation for the authorities
that are here at the port entrance
trying to deal with this
the solution that they're coming up with
now
is to get this mobile testing center
here but how quickly they can do that
and how quickly they can deal uh with
the many lorries that are here
um is another question i mean we you
know it's
i think many hours into days just to get
rid of
what we see just around the dover area